my last book 100 million dollar offers
just crossed its one year anniversary it
sold over 200 000 copies with no
publisher no advertising campaign I
launched it before I had an audience it
is Alex from other here and I have
absolutely nothing to sell he was truly
off of Word of Mouth just launched a
brand new book it's a 100 million dollar
offers 100 million dollar offers and so
people read the book and shared the book
you need to create a grant and slam off
if people aren't sharing it on their own
then it's not worth promoting because
it's not good enough I think that when I
die the thing that I will be most proud
of is not the businesses that I've built
but the books that I've written I think
the books will outlive anything else and
I think that they will help more people
that's why I spend right now about 20 to
25 hours a week every week on my book
most authors pretty much only do that
they're right for four or five hours a
day and then they end their day for me I
write for four or five hours then I
start my day and so I wanted to do one
deep dive video into my writing process
the most powerful ability in the world
to influence other people is the ability
to tell stories that's because you can
both educate and entertain with stories
it literally changes people's brain main
waves when they're listening to your
story and they become more suggestible
so I'm going to break down the elements
of Storytelling how to edit a story to
make it better how to increase the
stakes that make it interesting to a
reader and how to do it in such a way
that you're actually breaking someone's
beliefs that you can actually influence
how they behave and once you have that
ability you can use it to sell you can
use it to educate you can use it to
teach to reshape someone's beliefs you
can change someone's character you can
give skills like there's endless ways
and it's the most effective way to
communicate to other people that there
is if you want to write a book the way
that I outline these things is what's
the point of writing this book to begin
with what is the problem that I'm
solving the vast majority of books that
are written right now are not written
because they want to serve the audience
they're written because the author wants
to make money from the book accolades
whatever most books are not worth
reading when writing and Publishing a
book became easier was about the 1960s
from that point going forward the amount
of books that were published you know
has exploded 1.6 million books are
written per year the reason people
publish has changed but I believe that
great writing comes from a place of
wanting to add to the body of knowledge
and when you do that then it allows to
compress five years into three hours or
four hours for somebody and that's where
a book becomes valuable next is kind of
like how do you come up with a big idea
and then after that I'll talk about the
editing stuff from a big idea standpoint
this is what actually takes me the
longest period of time which is
narrowing down the focus of the book to
a single problem to be solved I have to
answer the question very truthfully what
do I want someone to get from this book
the first book offers is people don't
know what to sell and so that's the
first problem somebody has before they
can make money is they have to know what
they're actually going to sell someone
which is the offer and so that's why I
started my book series there the next
problem is they don't have anyone to
sell it to they need leads and so the
idea is that when someone's gonna meet
somebody else I have to think like where
does my book come out in the wild just
saying like oh I read this great book
you should read it some people read that
but where I think it's best is where
someone's like dude I wish I had more
leads people were like oh if you're
suffering from that you have to read
this book because now it's a solution to
someone's problem the problem with most
books is that they don't actually solve
anyone's problem because they basically
name hundreds of problems and don't
completely solve any of them so I would
rather very narrowly Define the problem
and then solve it completely a good book
is a complete solution to a narrowly
defined problem and so what is the
problem that we're solving and then what
are the ways that I would think about
solving the problem usually it's going
to be three to six big buckets that are
going to fit for solving a specific
problem once I have those buckets I'm
going to think what are the experiences
that I've had that have shaped this
belief that I have about this like why
do I think there are these three to six
buckets it's like well this is what
happened in this time that's what shaped
this part this is what happened this
time this would shape that part when I
saw the charity event at Arnold
Schwarzenegger's home that we were
invited to I saw scarcity in action
about how how are they able to sell
these things that were never normally
worth more than ten thousand dollars for
a hundred thousand dollars there was all
these other factors at play so it was a
very good story for me to transfer like
why scarcity is important there's lots
of different Frameworks for trading
stories I will give you the one that has
been useful for me you have a setting
which is where this is happening you
have the character the person who's
doing the doing you have the desire
which is the thing they want you have
some sort of struggle why they can't get
it you have some sort of Eureka moment
that changes things achieving the
Victory and then some sort of resolution
they talk about this as the Heroes 2
Journeys but not all stories have Heroes
that have two Journeys but the
externally internal and you want to tell
both the external is what you can see
with your eyes if you were in the room
the internal is what you'd have to
experience as the person emotionally and
see we want to weave both of those
together in the story and so someone
might have the victory but it might feel
empty and so it's like we want to tell
both sides of that there's two kind of
rules of thought that I use one is I
want to use all five senses so I talk
about I Smell What I Hear What I see
what I can touch how things feel like I
could feel the back of the chair against
me my back was sore because I've been
sitting for hours so I could set the
setting that way by kind of describing
rather than telling number two is you
want to show rather than telling so I'll
give an example that Stephen King uses
in his book on writing which is a great
book instead of saying Cheryl walked in
she was his ex-wife he might say
something like he struck the spot on his
finger that was still bleached from
where his wedding ring used to be you
show the situation to the reader rather
than telling them and that is also true
of great copy of great marketing of
great ads is that you want to
demonstrate rather than saying it well
then what details do you include because
I could spend an entire book to describe
this room but if I I just said there was
a pelt on the wall and it's made of wood
and there was a view of water and pine
trees you probably have an idea of what
kind of place this is if you want to be
selective about the details that you're
choosing to call out because otherwise
you're just wasting time now if the Pelt
that I have on the wall in my mind's eye
is a deer and in your mind is a buffalo
does it change the story and if the
answer is no then we don't need to go in
more detail on it you want to be Vivid
in your description about the things
that matter for me I've always had
stories heavily ingrained in books
because I want to bring the experience
that taught the lesson with it because
then it gives context to why the
framework that I introduce in that
chapter is useful so what makes a story
interesting I like to think of it as one
main thing which is stakes and struggle
I can give you a simple story I was at
home I was hungry I couldn't find any
food I realized I had my phone and I
ordered ubereats ubereats arrived I ate
I was satisfied that is a story it's not
a very interesting story but it is a
story if I tell that same story and I
would to say I was hungry I'm a diabetic
if I don't eat I could die and there was
no food in the house as I was rummaging
around my vision started to narrow I
started getting cold sweats and I was
like am I going to be able to get food
before I pass out my family's out of
town they're not going to be able to
find me and so I started having thoughts
about like is this how they're going to
find me my body on the floor what are my
kids going to think all of a sudden I
created stakes in the story The Reason
game shows are inherently interesting is
that they literally put money on it so
that there are Stakes that's why those
exist imagine you were watching a bunch
of poker players play and the chips were
meaningless
like steaks is what makes things
interesting so there was a textbook that
my buddy Dr kashy also sent me to create
better ads write better copy and
ultimately write things that are more
interesting what are the factors of
newsworthiness and so if you think about
newsworthiness it's just what are things
that make things interesting and so
there were seven components the more of
these components that you can tie into a
story The more of a story it is and they
literally even talk about stories in the
news like what's the story the first one
is recency how far away the event was to
the thing so if you think about you know
hopping on Trends as fast as possible
when you're telling stories the recency
with which the thing occurred to when
you're telling the story makes it more
interesting the second one is impact of
the event so if there's a story but it
has no impact on the reader or The
Listener it's going to be limited which
is why it's on the job of the author to
a select the stories that they're going
to tell and then make sure that they're
bridging why this is important for you
as they're telling the story and then
they tie it to the action items
especially if you're teaching that you
want someone to take as a result of that
the third is prominence like if Kim
Kardashian sneezes it becomes
interesting because of how prominent she
is and so if you can involve characters
that have prominence in a story then you
make the story more interesting in and
of itself the next one is proximity so
it's close to homeness if you will if I
tell you a story of a house that's
burning down it might be kind of
interesting but if I told you it was
your neighbor next door it's probably
much more interesting to you if you have
an ad and you're marketing to a local
market the closer you can get the
headline if it says rather than like
Baltimore Maryland it says Towson
Maryland which is a sub suburb or
whatever they're going to be much more
inclined to listen to the next thing
that makes something interesting is
conflict whether that's natural or
whether it's between people we're here
recording this video and a man with a
gun walks in all of a sudden this got
way more interesting and so it's because
there's conflict there's tension and
there's unresolved there's mystery the
next one is how unusual is this thing is
there something odd or bizarre or unique
about this particular situation or story
like if you see something that you
expect your brain doesn't say oh let's
pay more attention to this because it
matches the patterns that you expect and
so the idea is that you want someone to
cast a pattern or expectation under your
story and then all of a sudden you shift
it and they're like whoa and then their
brain will divert resources towards the
story because it's not matching the
patterns that they already had in their
mind which means they needed to create
attention to reconcile the conflict
between what they expect and what is
reality and the last one is the amount
of times you can update this is a little
bit more around news but it's like how
many times can you update someone on the
same thing right that's why news stories
love giving updates up we're pressing
news right from the crime scene when
you're telling a story might not be
always able to do that if you're fixed
in a story setting you don't have to
have all of these things but if you have
two three or you know of these things in
one story it makes it a much more
interesting story hey guys the much
awaited sequel to 100 million dollar
offers is 100 million dollar leads it is
coming out in the next 12 months
realistically probably six months if you
want to get on the early bird list
because last time we sold out in less
than an hour so if you want to get on
the early bird list and just make sure
that you have a guaranteed copy ready
for you for distribution so you're gonna
use it in getting more leads in your
business go to acquisition.com anywhere
and just opt in and then you'll get
automatically added to that list so that
we can send you the link the moment it
launches once you have that you have a
way to tell a story now it's like okay
well then how do I bridge that into a
wirefram for a book and so for me my
general rule of thumb is that I just put
stories in where I feel like it starts
to get heavy I want to deliver as much
of the things they need to do in their
business and right when I start to feel
like it's heavy I zoom out and I create
a story that creates more context and we
dive back in I have my big problem the
supporting arguments that lead up to
that single thing and then I have the
stories about how I learn each of those
things to fill in the blanks for that
book and then the framework for each
chapter now once I had that I have a
general idea of how I want to go about
solving that problem everyone has
different writing processes for me I go
as far as I can until I realize that I
have a logical inconsistency or an
inconsistency with my own experiences
that would prove my theory or model
wrong at that point this is the part
where most people don't want to do it I
go back to the beginning I adjust my
assumptions and then I restart the book
and I write it again and I usually get a
little further and then I realize that
something is wrong with the model and
the bigger it is the more I have to
adjust the book and start over again
models have to be two things they have
to be useful and they have to be valid
there's too many things in life that you
don't want to ReDiscover and redo the
work so your brain creates these mental
shortcuts these mental checklists that
you go through in your head a lot of
them are not documented so all the
framework really is is documenting the
checklist you already go through there's
always a process everyone goes through
to make a decision as simple as they may
be which serial am I going to grab the
one that's closest to me you know what I
mean like it could be as simple as that
there's a framework that you use and it
is useful now the question is how valid
is it and the validity of a framework
depends on how many different
circumstances it can be applied to and
also still work the very valuable
Frameworks like equals mc squared apply
in every one that we have found to date
which is what makes it so valid when I'm
testing a framework I know the
situations it does work and so then I
start testing it in new situations
seeing if it's still valid and if it
isn't valid I go back to the original
framework and say how would I need to
adjust this so it would incorporate both
and then I tested another situation in
another business situation until
eventually I get a framework that I
can't find a way that it's wrong the
longest process for me is ideating all
the pieces that are going to be in the
book The Next longest process is
actually writing the first draft from
there I go through my heavy editing of
going from 12th grade language to third
grade language with more pictures my
goal is is that when someone reads the
stuff that I have that they spend as
much of their mental capacity on
consuming the concepts and not
translating the words into things they
understand the average American reads
somewhere in the neighborhood of fifth
to seventh grade depending on where you
read which means half of Americans read
below that there's a free app called
hemingwayapp.com that literally is just
a pace box and when you paste your words
into the box it highlights it and says
this is too complicated adverb passive
if you want to train yourself to be a
better writer using it gives you
immediate feedback because as soon as
you change it the color changes and so
when you talk about changing people's
behavior having something that
immediately gives you feedback when you
make a change is the best way to
reinforce Behavior quickly and so I
think it's one of the best teaching
writing tools that exists it's so simple
you'll be amazed at how much better your
writing comes out so if you have a
paragraph and you can eliminate a
sentence and the paragraph's meaning
stays the same eliminate it if you can
use shorter sentences versus a long
sentence it is better to use the shorter
sentence if you have a shorter word it
is better to use it try to eliminate
adverbs whenever possible really
whenever possible like whenever you're
like I'm really not sure still trying to
eliminate it most times when you see an
adverb it's because you did not use the
right verb I walked quickly it would be
much better to say I ran I always use
Simple tenses so rather than like would
have liked to I just say wanted or
wanted to if you can't make something
sound simple it's because you don't get
it not them from there I go and send it
to four to eight of my like ideal
readers people whose opinions I value
but don't hold me in high enough esteem
that they're not going to tell me the
truth so they're like hey I had
questions here this didn't make sense or
the standard contradiction or something
else whatever and so they send me back
their notes again I use Stephen King
because he's just like my hero for
writing but he's like if you get lots of
different feedback for everyone then you
did a good job if everyone's saying the
same thing he's like you probably should
change it once I get the feedback from
those readers I create what would be
considered my third and final draft then
I send that to an editor for like
grammar typos Etc and then at that point
I have what I would consider my finished
book I spent a thousand hours on a book
roughly and a lot of people can't
comprehend that like level of work which
is also why most people can't make good
stuff people think that writing a book
is like just literally getting the word
count to a book size and then slapping a
cover on it and shipping it which is why
there are so many bad books there's this
visual that Stephen King gives that I
think is like the best visual and it
gave me hope about writing he said
writing is walking uphill with a bag of
rocks where you keep adding rocks the
higher up the hill you go so the longer
you've been writing something the
heavier it feels he's like you just have
to have the endurance to be able to go
through the hard work pruning through
the writing and killing The Darlings
really like I spent so much time on the
section but it shouldn't be in the book
with this particular book I went through
eight full drafts so it's about 600
pages of writing to create what is now
200 pages of version 8 of the book so
with the leads book I can tell you the
sections of the book are understanding
how to talk about leads get leads get
other people to get you leads get even
more leads do it those are the sections
of the book right like that's very
simple and then within each of those
subsections is the different types of
ways you can collect leads and so but
all of them aligned that single point
which is how do I get people more leads
if this thing that I'm writing does not
apply to that you take it out I'm
shooting for a book a year we'll see if
I get there but like that's what that's
my like mental back of napkin goal is
you know I still have to like run all
the companies and make these videos and
stuff so if you took some takeaways that
you can write into your stories into the
content that you make into your
marketing into your advertising into the
stuff you use to sell people's things
you should check out my content video of
how we gained 1.2 million followers in
six months just using a standard
step-by-step content strategy which I
break down in all the detail and the
stages that you can apply them within
your business right now